We all sleep.
And by “we all” I mean all animals
from bugs to bird to people.
And sleep looks the same on us, from the outside.
We lie down, close our eyes, stay still
But on the inside
- what our brains are doing during sleep -
was thought to be unique to birds and mammals.
During sleep for these animals, the brain exhibits
two different patterns of activity -
slow-wave sleep and rapid-eye movement or REM sleep.
But now, it looks like reptiles
have a similar pattern of activity in their sleep:
REM sleep alternating with a slow-wave type sleep
throughout the resting period.
Researchers were able to measure this type of sleep
in lizards for the first time using implanted electrodes,
infrared cameras and elaborate analysis.
One unique aspect of lizard sleep -
the lizard’s sleep cycle is only about 60-90 seconds long
In humans, our complex sleep cycles
last 60-90 minutes each!
Does this mean that lizards
have short, frequent dreams?
It’s still too early to tell if lizards
or even birds dream during their sleep
But what we do know is that our sleep patterns
are a lot older than once thought—
at least 300 million years old.
Because lizards may be more similar to
our shared common ancestor,
studying sleep in the reptile brain may be the best way
to learn more about how sleep works for everyone.